alors aujourd'hui je vous présente une
rareté dans nos collections puisque
c'est la hub de brobo un oiseau qui a
vécu à l'île de la réunion et qui est
endémique de la réunion c'est à dire
qu'on ne le trouve nulle part ailleurs
dans le monde et qui a totalement
disparu au milieu du 19e siècle sans
doute suite à ce qu'on appelle une ipo
ti c'est à dire une épidémie soit 2 de
virus ou d'une bactérie qui a décimé
toute la population donc il n'ya plus
que une vingtaine de spécimens dans tous
les musées du monde entier et un seul
spécimen à la réunion et celui ci est
inscrit à l'inventaire sous le numéro
1996 donc frégé lipus varius donc de la
famille des surdités c'est à dire des
étourneaux un peu comme le martin